so I am super excited to be starting a
brand new series on this channel this is
a beginner to master speed run as you
can see above my head I'll be starting
at a 400 ELO on chess.com and trying to
work my way up until Master Level or
above hopefully 2200 plus and I'm not
sure how many games it will take but
this won't be the traditional speed rung
where I'm trying to do it as quickly as
possible but the goal with the series is
to be as educational as possible and to
show what it takes to be different
players at different rating levels how
to punish beginner mistakes intermediate
mistakes and really show the core chess
fundamentals that you need to know to
level up your own game and take your
rating to the next level so with all
that said I'm super excited to hop in
now as you maybe can see my rating on
chess.com is still 1202 as maybe you
watched my recent video you'll know that
I had to play a bunch of games on this
account to get an established rating and
I emailed chess.com admins and I'm
waiting for them to reset the rating
back to 400 that way it will be less
volatile so as I wait I do want to thank
the sponsor of today's video which is
betterhelp so if you're a human like me
and not a robot then chances are that
you face some challenging times in your
life
is something interfering with your
happiness are you having trouble
achieving your goals
regardless of whether you have a
clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or you're just
going through a hard time and wants
someone to talk to therapy can really
help you take a different approach to
your life and that's why I'm super
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor betterhelp their mission is to
make therapy more affordable and
accessible regardless of where you live
they're an online platform that makes
finding a therapist as easy as beating
martinbot I'm sorry Martin you're a
robot therapy is not for you but again
if you're human all you need to do is
fill out a few questions and better help
can match you with a professional
therapist in as little as a few days if
you want to try it out click the link in
the video description betterhelp.com
Eric Rosen to get 10 off your first
month of Better Health
again I want to think better help for
sponsoring this video and making therapy
accessible to more people all over the
world and now let's get back to the
chess
all right so I'm a little bit nervous I
don't know why it feels like I'm
starting chess for the first time
but my rating has been reset to 400 and
I'm just going to hop in start a 10
minute game
and first opponents playing K Min D
Winnie
sorry if I butchered that
uh opponent took a little bit of time on
the first move but plays D4
and I'm gonna stick with uh very simple
and just classical openings for the most
part I'm not going to do anything too
tricky or trappy in the opening we see
Knight C3 which at a higher level
usually signifies that white wants to go
for Joe Bava London
um at beginner level this move isn't
super recommended because generally in
d-pawn openings the C Pawn likes to come
to C4 or C3 and light coming in front of
the C Pawn doesn't harmonize in the best
way
but of course it's still very playable
we see Knight to F3
and in this position it's really
question how to develop the minor pieces
and in these were several games
um I'm gonna try not to play like
Mainline opening Theory but try and play
they're very easy to understand manner
and generally like in the opening you
want to Castle as quickly as possible
like get out this King side bishop and
uh and Castle uh but the problem with
playing E6 is it will block in this
bishop on C8
so I'm gonna play the move here Bishop
to F5
and simple plan is to play E6 and then
bring out the bishop and then Castle
and I'm actually playing a reverse
London system uh now opponent gives me a
check
um there's a few ways to avoid the check
I'm gonna play C6
this is a very common I would say
beginner inaccuracy this bishop B5 check
because usually it doesn't help white in
any way and especially when the pawn can
block then this bishop is gonna have to
move again
but I will say my opponent hasn't really
done any like serious blunders yet just
playing a few small inaccuracies like
this Knight C3 and Bishop B5
and now I have a decision to make uh
Bishop D3 challenging my Bishop on F5
and there are a few options here I could
leave the bishop on F5 but if I allow
white to take
I take back and have the whole pawns and
probably don't want to to enter those
sort of lines
um I think the move I'll play is Bishop
G6
and this is a very common approach in
such situations where I'm leaving the
tension I'm basically offering if white
wants to trade then I'll be happy to
take back with the H Pawn
and this would be a good example of
double pawns where the Rook would then
have the open H file hpond would be a
square closer to the center which is
always nice
and one thing I've I learned
um a bit later in my chess career it's
kind of obvious when you think about it
but with pawns on the A and each files
they're basically half as powerful as
pawns on the G through b files because
they only control one square
but when I move towards the center now
the pollen controls two squares
and I do have double pawns but they're
not a little weak
and uh okay my opponent is very much
following opening principles really
hasn't done anything clearly wrong yet
um but I have a very solid position and
as I mentioned earlier
my plan was to Castle as quickly as
possible but because the H file is now
open
I want to keep my Rook on h8 and use it
as
hopefully an attacking weapon and I'm
going to start here with Bishop 2 D6
and already we can see some
harmonization between the rook and the
bishop
my plan is very likely to play a move
like Queen C7 maybe Knight G4
and um yeah hopefully we'll see a nice
example of how to orchestrate an attack
from the early middle game
but I will say I'm impressed with my
opponent's play so far
given the rating I was expecting to
maybe be completely winning if I move 10
but it's not going to be the case
but uh yeah I'm trying to show no mercy
here
opponent plays Queen E1
which
it is a slightly awkward move
um kind of signifies that like
maybe doesn't know what to do although
this move does perhaps support the idea
of playing E4
and I have to be careful because if I
allow E4 and E5 then these pieces can be
exploited
so there's a move here I really like I'm
just gonna play it as Knight E4
and while this doesn't directly attack
the H Pawn
I'm opening up the line for the queen
I'm also creating a situation where if
white takes a knight
I'll take back and I'll okay we're gonna
see this play out I'm basically removing
a key defender of the H2 Pawn
and now white is in big big trouble
because if the light moves here
okay but Knight moves here which is a
free piece
um
after the game I'll analyze a few of the
different options uh I could take the
Knight or I could take on each two first
I think I'd rather take on H2 first so
why not take a pawn with check
force a king to each one
and then
yeah eventually I'll take the knights
I think white is now realizing
their predicaments
yeah this did escalate pretty quickly
um I guess I didn't get a winning
position by move did I yeah I did I did
get a winning position by move ten
um but goes to show the danger that
white
was facing from early on with this open
H file
after the game I'll share what white
could have done better uh yeah so here
I'll take the knights
and it's still a question of how to
checkmates
but it's very nice having a lot of
Firepower on the king side I take the
pawn unleashing The Rook
white has only two legal moves here
uh both of which will
will face checkmates
um really any bishop move on my next
move will be checkmates
uh to be stylish I'll play Bishop C7
and that's uh discover checkmate with
the queen
so pretty quick game
um but I think this is actually a very
instructive game and
yeah I was debating
before playing this first game if I'll
record multiple games for this one video
and I think I'll probably play one more
game after this one at least uh to make
the video at least a little bit longer
but let me show uh what whites
should have done
um
probably already in this position white
should have sensed some danger and a
simple approach here would be to play a
move like H3 or G3 H3 essentially
undermines a rook
and no longer allows me to be pressuring
upon an H2 G3 would undermine the bishop
and these would be relatively like safer
defensive moves
um of course earlier too there were
probably some better options for lights
um yeah generally this this move Pawn E3
uh is not desirable when you have the
bishop still on on C1 so a move like
Bishop F4 or Bishop G5 would have been a
little bit better
but going back to really the key moment
here when I played Knight E4 White had
to be super super careful and um I think
taking was a game losing blunder
although I'm realizing here white could
have played 95. which would have saved
the knights and blocked my attack uh
against each Pawn
but things would still be looking very
good here it moved like F6 attacking the
knights Knights essentially pinned at H
Pawn I think this would lead to a very
very pleasant position for black
I also want to show move I was expecting
was Knight D2 this would walk in to
Bishop takes H2 and here there's
actually a cool mating idea Bishop G3
King G1
and then I can sacrifice a rook and
after the king takes the queen can come
in with Chuck after King G1 Queen H2
mates this is a a really nice and uh
pretty common mating sequence with the
open H file against the castle King
so I hope there's some lessons to take
away from that one a good game to my
opponents I think play the fine opening
just
um got a little bit uh
careless with uh with the King side play
okay so that was the first game uh I
gained 26 rating points so I think my
rating is still a little bit volatile
but um maybe it's a good thing to kind
of speed through these lower rating
levels
and I'll do one more
playing a strange deja vu I don't think
I've played this opponent before
lots of some Deja Vu I've been
forgetting
uh playing E4
and um I'm gonna stick with a classical
opening repertoire we see the
Scandinavian which is definitely very
common especially at lower levels
and generally against this opening the
best move is just to take and most
people take back with Queen
we'll see what my opponent wants to do
here Knight F6 so this is uh I guess
what we call the modern Scandinavian
defense
um it's an opening I sometimes like to
play from the back side black is staying
flexible uh offering to give me a chance
to defend the pawn if I want
and there are a bunch of moves here
probably the most common move is D4 a
long black to take the pawn but there's
also C4 there's Bishop B5 check
um
I'm debating
like what the easiest path is to
development
I don't want to like be materialistic
and try and save the pawn like after C4
there's weird gambits with E6 not sure
if my opponent will be aware of uh the
tricky gambits but I'm gonna play in a
very uh patient and solid style Knight
F3
giving block the chance to take the pawn
with
the queen or the knights
but my plan is basically to develop my
minor pieces as quickly as possible
and I'll start here with Knight C3
attacking the queen
this is what we call developing with
Tempo I bring out a minor piece and
black has to waste time moving the queen
again and black actually chose one of
the worst squares for the queen so now
the queen is aligned with the King and
this is a very uh very classic tactic
Bishop E5 pinning the queen
and uh
yeah oh no oh no your queen
a slight opening tragedy for my
opponents but a very important lesson um
and generally in the lower levels you
should be very very cautious when
bringing out your queen early of course
there's many exceptions to the rules
like even even this position is is very
playable the best move one of the best
moves was Queen A5 or queen D6
but um yeah this is maximum punishment
we'll take the queen
and we're going to see my opponent uh
try and fight on
and generally when you win material
early in the game there's a few things
to keep in mind okay Knight D4 very very
aggressive move if I take I lose my
queen back
wants to double my pawns on the king
side which I can't really avoid
but
it's nice being up a queen because I'm
very happy to trade and that's one of
the things to keep in mind when you're
on material generally trades will
benefit you because then you're just
simplifying further giving the opponent
less chances to come back
and even though my king is more open
uh yeah Black's not getting any attack
especially after
I take the bishop as well
okay The Rook wants to take the pawn
let's be very safe defend
playing a game like this definitely
gives me a lot of nostalgia like reminds
me when I was first learning chess at
the age of seven I'm sure I had a lot of
games like this from the lock side where
I'd blunder early and
um part of progressing as a chess player
is just learning from your mistakes
learning from other people's mistakes
I hope people watching this game can
learn from some of my opponent's
mistakes and learn kind of the the
proper principles to approach uh the
early stage of the game
a G5 attacking the knights
so
I'm keeping I'm gonna keep taking free
stuff as it comes
uh showing no mercy here
and we're getting very close to
some potential checkmating ideas
I'm gonna grab the pawn on B7
even though I'm abandoning my H Pawn
um the King on E8 is way more of a
Target than my king on G1
and I have a few tracks I have Queen C8
which would uh win The Rook if I want
but I'm more interested in checkmating
so let's start with Queen C8
this forces King E7
and rather than taking the Rook
I'm just gonna bring more attackers to
uh
trying to harass a black king
and we're entering a position which we
can basically call a mating nuts where I
have a lot of pieces swarming around the
king's already maybe getting a little
bit short on squares
and generally when you're trying to
Checkmate the king it's helpful to bring
in as many pieces as possible it's also
helpful to keep checking so black won't
have time to
use any of the other pieces to help out
so Bishop F4
also developing with Tempo gaining time
black has to move the king
and um yeah this is white to move
Checkmate in one
feel free to pause the video if you want
to find it but move is Queen C7
and that concludes game two of the speed
run
so I gained 21 points from that game
and I think as I win more games like
rating gains will slow down a little bit
um but that was another
um another pretty straightforward game I
had this decision early on I think if I
was playing like a grand master opponent
I would have played Bishop B5 is like
the more
testing move theoretically but Knight F3
I was really just trying to stick with
the idea of trying to Castle as quickly
as possible getting the king safe
and we saw that
when my opponents left the queen and
king vulnerably placed then bad things
happen
so I don't think there's much more to
discuss in this game
but I think I'm going to end it here we
have a two game episode for the first
video of the speed run
I'm realizing I still haven't
added a profile picture maybe for the
next video how to profile picture there
are a lot of suggestions in the comments
of my previous video what profile
picture I should have although I kind of
liked there is one idea of putting a
picture of like a young version of me
like maybe I'll I'll scour through some
family albums and find a picture from I
was four years old and then when I get
to 500 maybe I'll update the picture
it's a five-year-old me and so on
so um yeah let me know if you have
questions comments feedback happy to
hear them and also let me know uh how
many games you want to see in these
videos if two games is too little if you
just want to see one game per episode
um happy to adjust maybe I'll mix it up
as we continue the series uh but for now
I'm ending it good luck in your own
games and I'll see you guys soon